[Music]
in southern central bosnia just outside
the town of cone Yeats and behind a
quiet unassuming building in the
mountains lies a secret place a place
designed to survive a nuclear apocalypse
welcome to Tito's bunker construction of
the bunker was started by Yosef Broz
Tito the president of Yugoslavia at the
height of the Cold War it took 26 years
to complete and was a well kept top
secret for decades the horseshoe shaped
structure goes over 600 feet deep into
the mountain and is a maze of offices
conference rooms doors as well as living
quarters for Tito and his wife in the
event of a nuclear strike the bunker
could protect 350 of the most important
political and military persons in the
country the bunker was almost destroyed
in the early 90s during the Bosnian war
but went untouched remaining a time
capsule from the Cold War its bedrooms
bathrooms phones and typewriters still
lying ready for atomic war today the
bunker serves a more peaceful purpose as
a modern art museum housing one of the
most important and valuable art
collections in southern Europe built for
war between east and west
Tito's bunker is now a safe haven for
creative works from artists from around
the world
[Music]
you
[Music]